the president is making big concessions
on a massive
infrastructure deal to try and get
republicans on board but it may not be
enough he meets again today
with the gop's top negotiator after
shrinking
the size of his proposal and changing
how he plans to pay for it weijia zhang
is at the white house
wija what's in the president's latest
offer
oh good morning anthony and good morning
to everybody you are exactly right the
president is not only budging on the
size and what's in the plan but also
how to foot the bill you might remember
that initially he wanted
to raise the corporate tax rate from 21
to 28 percent
republicans staunchly opposed that in a
meeting wednesday with west virginia
senator shelly moore capito mr biden
proposed an
alternative a 15 percent minimum tax on
corporations
the goal there to target the dozens of
companies that have paid little to
nothing in federal corporate income
taxes
another concession from president biden
slashing new spending on infrastructure
from over two trillion dollars down to
roughly
one trillion that could be a tough
needle to thread though republicans have
so far only been willing to spend
about a quarter of that
weeja the president's concessions
particularly on the corporate tax rate
are likely to anger progressives in the
party what is
the calculation that the president's
making here so anthony the bottom line
is president biden
wants a bipartisan deal but you're right
we have to watch the reaction from
progressives
on the left today who see repealing
those
trump corporate tax cuts as a sticking
point now even though
mr biden might agree he understands that
keeping the corporate tax rate right
where it is
is a red line for republicans if they
don't make any progress however there's
always the option of using
the reconciliation process which would
only require
50 votes in the senate and then you'd
probably hear the talk
of raising those taxes again but
that's not a guarantee either they would
need every single democrat on board and
there are even some moderates like west
virginia's joe manchin who
are not there yet in fact he just said
he wants to see the white house and
republicans spend more time
on hammering out a deal anthony we just
hang at the white house thanks weeja